[Música]
buenas noches ya creo no
bueno yo voy a estar haciéndoles una
pequeña pregunta quiero saber
cuál es el superhéroe favorito bajo
superman espacio
[Música]
pero
bueno no sé si lo ven por ahí
este es mi superhéroe chapulín colorado
creo que todos conocen el chapulín
colorado roberto gómez bolaños hallado
con los años setenta creó este personaje
que es débil flaco miedoso y
descoordinado
y es decía roberto gómez bolaños
superman batman y demás no eran héroes
no eran superiores y no eran anti héroes
y lo decía porque ellos tenían
superpoderes tenían trajes tenían armas
y demás y eso les quitaba el miedo ellos
no tenían miedo no podían porque tener
miedo a nada en cambio el chapulín
colorado' es un personaje de carne y
hueso como les decía con un montón de
limitaciones pero él tenía la valentía
de enfrentar
traer en la adversidad la posibilidad de
enfrentarlo y siempre salir adelante y
conseguir su objetivo
además el chapulín colorado' es un
reflejo de nuestra sociedad
latinoamericana
no
perdón de nuevo
bueno nosotros tenemos un montón de
límites y el chapulín justamente
encuentra en estas limitaciones la
oportunidad para poder encontrar la
oportunidad en la adversidad nosotros
como sociedad generalmente admiramos
otras sociedades tipo la japonesa o las
europeas sociedades que están muy bien
planificadas organizadas y que
cuando se les presenta un contratiempo
se les presenta un algo que no estaba
dentro de su planificación por lo
general fracaso también nosotros los
latinoamericanos siempre encontramos con
creatividad la forma de salir adelante
eso es lo que hace el chapulín o sea
nosotros somos expertos en gestionar en
crisis
entonces el tablero es un reflejo de
nuestra sociedad
marc manson dice que la palentina no es
la ausencia del miedo la valentía es
sentir el miedo la duda la inseguridad y
decidir que algo más es más importante
el miedo no solamente tiene que ser algo
tenebroso o algún malhechor en el caso
de capulina el tripa se caía otros malos
que habían en su programa el miedo más
grande es el miedo al fracaso es ese
miedo que nos paraliza es ese miedo que
no nos permite salir de nuestra zona de
confort en mi casa en lo personal para
mí estar aquí es es una oportunidad de
enfrentar la adversidad de hecho cuando
me llamaron para invitarme estaba
inventando un montón de excusas de la
agenda llena viajes
en sí sí estaba de viaje pero pero bueno
siempre tuve el sueño para aquí y encima
de un escenario dando una charla ted
este es un desafío es algo nuevo para mí
enfrentar el miedo escénico y poder
hablar delante de un grupo de personas
extrañas es siempre
complicado para algunos
entonces estoy aquí enfrentando mis
miedos saliendo misión en confort
nosotros vivimos en una sociedad que
está acostumbrada a estar en la zona de
confort
somos muy cómodos
la gente que me conoce siempre me
escucho repetir lo mismo yo creo que
bolivia tiene un montón de limitantes un
montón de límite un montón de brechas
con otras sociedades con otros países
pero a su vez éstas limitan cias nos
brindan un sinfín de oportunidades
nos da la posibilidad de encontrar en
estas limitantes la oportunidad de
desarrollar con planificación con
organización y con mucho trabajo
opciones para poder desarrollar un
montón de cosas yo soy un creyente en él
creo que podemos y creo que tenemos con
qué
en robbins antes de nuestra época dice
que los límites más difíciles de romper
y superar son los límites
tiene una teoría que dice que el éxito
es 80% mental y 20% estrategia ya eso
les sumaría la acción porque si no
tenemos la valentía para superar el
miedo no hay acción entonces sin acción
no hay la posibilidad de desarrollar
ningún tipo de estrategia ningún tipo de
amén entonces ahí yo los invito a
superar ese miedo a animarse a enfrentar
los miedos a salir de esa zona de
confort
yo siempre trato de explicarlo todo con
fútbol creo que al final el fútbol es el
producto del consumo masivo más grande
del mundo entero
quien no consume fuego de alguna u otra
manera aquí podemos ver desde 1926
bolivia juego a 467 partidos hasta la
fecha de hoy medios partidos amistosos y
partidos oficiales hemos ganado 99
partidos hemos empatado 111 y hemos
perdido 257 veces
esto hace que hayamos perdido más del
55% de las veces que hemos jugado
nos hace crecer en un mundo de fracasos
nos hace sentir perdedores más aún las
nuevas generaciones que no han tenido la
posibilidad de ver
vive en el mundial o ver la copa américa
el 97 donde fuimos subcampeones
pero yo veo aquí una oportunidad yo veo
aquí que nosotros con un poco de
organización con un poco de
planificación con un poco de cambiar esa
mentalidad que tenemos la mayoría salir
de la zona de confort de salir de esa
comodidad
tenemos la opción de poder hacer algo
nuevo de hacer algo mejor creo que
haciendo un poquito más de lo que
estamos acostumbrados vamos a hacer algo
mejor de lo que ya se ha hecho para mí
esta es una oportunidad
este es mi libro favorito es player
la web para serie
básicamente el libro te habla de por qué
algunas personas son exitosas y otras no
menciona casos de éxitos como los vídeos
como steve jobs bill gates varios
deportistas y básicamente la resume en
una teoría la teoría de las 10.000 horas
de práctica
él dice para que una persona sea
considerada experta en algún rubro hay
que tener más de 10.000 horas de
práctica
yo a eso le sumó la pasión el amor por
lo que uno más es mucho más sencillo
siempre hacer algo que uno ama algo que
le apasiona que hacer algo que no nos
gusta hacer
yo como decía la presentación soy un
eterno agradecido porque he encontrado
temprana edad lo que realmente me
apasionaba
es el fuck
tuve la suerte y el privilegio de haber
llegado a jugar profesionalmente jugué
en the strongest universitario que
selección mexicana sub-17 sub-20
pero tuve más lesiones que partidos
jugados
tenía miedo le tengo miedo al fracaso de
alguna u otra manera
[Música]
puede la verdad para mí muy difícil
asimilar la frustración me pelié
totalmente con el fútbol no veía fútbol
no iba a la cancha empecé a trabajar
como ingeniero en telecomunicaciones y
bueno yo estudié mientras jugaba
a través de cinco años como ingeniero
lejos
y pasaron cinco años para que mi pasión
o lo que llevamos por el juego me llame
nuevamente a esta industria me animé a
enfrentar el miedo de renunciar a algo
seguro que tengo un trabajo muy bueno
tenía una paga muy buena tenía 15
sueldos tiene seguro médico tenía un
buen puesto hacía planificación de
proyectos en el área de tecnología
manejando proyectos de hasta 100
millones de dólares
pero no era lo que me apasionado no era
lo que a mí me gustaba hacer
tomé la decisión de enfrentar mis miedos
que dirán a mi familia amigos que te
preguntan de qué vas a dirigir o qué vas
a hacer no sabía cómo hacer una empresa
no tenía idea de cómo
hacer administración flujo nada nada
nada nada nada
pero sabía que era
me llamaba a creer que hoy hoy bueno
después de un tiempo ya
es mucho más sencillo hablar hacia atrás
no casi cinco años de que tome la
decisión de renunciar tenemos la agencia
deportiva de asesoramiento integral 360
invictus es la primera en tener una
empresa real en lo que esto deportivo en
varias unidades de negocio
hacemos logística deportiva organización
de eventos marketing deportivo
asesoramiento para temas de becas
deportivas en los eeuu el tema de
representación y el asesoramiento para
entrenadores también en lo que es
jurídico legal
etcétera
tenemos la revista cábala obviamente
hace un proceso muy largo y muy duro
pero todavía tenemos bien presente el
propósito es aportar con nuestro granito
de arena para mejorar la situación del
internacional y profesionalizando
diferentes rubros diferentes ámbitos
como el periodismo deportivo el
marketing deportivo
y es de nuevo lo mismo hemos encontrado
una oportunidad dentro de las limitantes
que nosotros tenemos con el país
yo soy un fiel creyente en este en esta
en este lema que dijo nelson mandela el
deporte tiene el poder de cambiar el
mundo en el poder de unir a la gente
les comentaba bueno haciendo una
retrospectiva de todo lo que hemos hecho
como agencia deportiva todos los logros
que tenemos estamos trabajando con los
mejores deportistas y atletas del país
tenemos una empresa consolidada
pero todavía hay mucho por hacer hay
mucho mucho por desarrollar
y uno de nuestros sueños es precisamente
ir a un mundial
yo tengo el anhelo de ver a mi selección
nuevamente un mundial tengo el anhelo de
poder en algún momento representar un
jugador en una liga importante
y creo que el cambio empieza en uno
mismo
y cambiar la forma de pensar cambiar la
forma de actuar de uno mismo
aquí bueno esta es una de las de las
prendas que nosotros hemos desarrollado
para para pablo escobar la primera vez
que se hizo algo así
en bolivia hemos creado una línea de
ropa exclusiva para un atleta
profesional
hemos creado seis prendas y las seis han
agotado
entonces realmente hemos encontrado una
oportunidad dentro de las limitantes que
tenemos como país y aquí nos hemos
basado mucho en el tema de
evitar las excusas de tener los sueños
más grandes en nuestras excusas
basados en el lema de insistir persistir
resistir y jamás desistir no
mientras más sueños sean mientras los
sueños sean más grandes queda prohibido
para terminar quiero mencionarles una
frase que me decía mis padres era muy
niño él me decía sé diferente y achicó a
10hs en latín significa hagas lo que
hagas hazlo bien
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i